[Music]
what's up reject nation oh we're not
stopping spider war in time oh yeah
we'll see next week at the eternals
premiere yeah buddy we got this video
today called spiderman no way home toby
and andrew lee spider-man vs spider-man
scene
poor k
let's see what's going on today people
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and of course
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some rather interesting leagues
that i personally really really hope are
true and they are coming from an insider
that has gotten things right about
spider-man knowing home in the past
we'll see about that i've been hearing
rumors that the other two spider-man
toby mcguire and andrew garfield will
show up in the last scene of the last
trailer and this is also something that
i would really love to happen because it
would give us an official confirmation
so this leak is coming from a mysterious
man
in the past so this actually might be
true what i'm about to read and there's
some good plot details in here but
really the big things to take away are
about andrew and toby it goes on to
eventually say that at some point in the
movie andrew and toby spider-man fall
into new york city into tom holland's
main universe the press then start to
report that they have seen more than one
spider-man and other people as well have
been reporting that they've seen more
than one spider-man as well now this
obviously starts to make peter tom
holland's peter very very confused and
he starts to think that maybe mysterio
is still alive and this is some sort of
an illusion that he is casting oh
mysterio is the master of illusions and
he's the one that is framing peter
parker currently and i personally think
that he is still alive he was such a
great villain i hope they wouldn't waste
him like that and again he's the master
of illusions he's the trickster it
definitely wouldn't be a big surprise if
he's alive that would actually be a
great way to keep the mysterio presents
alive and i personally
would love it if that is indeed how it
takes place in the movie i would love it
if we don't actually see toby and andrew
come into our universe that you're just
watching this solely from the
perspective of tom holland's peter
parker that way you're in his shoes when
the questioning is happening of like oh
my god is that mysterio because i think
it'll undercut it if you if you're
really focusing on the other two
spiderman the whole time well yeah if
you're just cutting between them all of
them there's like no tension whatsoever
in that part of the story whereas yeah
if you had it be at least a mystery to
peter and him thinking like no no this
is all part of it he's trying to frame
me even more yeah that could ramp up the
tension
especially leading into the later parts
yeah and better build up to when you do
see that exactly
and here's where things get really
really cool if this is true it says that
when the three spider-man first meet
each other they'll fight each other in
what this league describes as an epic
battle on their first encounter
apparently they are all suspicious of
each other and none of them understand
what is happening and it makes perfect
into a sense
different universe and all of a sudden
they see two others imposter the
confusion is definitely going to be real
now i don't think either of them are
going to be out to really hurt one
another rather i think that they're just
going to be somewhat defensive obviously
if you jump into a new universe you have
no idea what's going on and you're
probably not going to trust anybody well
that feels very classic marvel too
if they were to encounter each other
they would break into a fight right away
there's a threat and just look at the
first avengers movie too you know i
think that's that's his classic
essential part of any team-up is they
got to fight each other to find each
other first before they team up you know
to be a team
that would be a great live-action fight
too and if there's a way they can
visually realize the different ways they
move
because i honestly can't define it for
you guys right here right now but if i
were to see it on screen and they
captured that then that would be like
whoa oh
yeah yeah that'll be the coolest where
it's like a subconscious processing of
what's happening of of of the
differences kind of like what's already
happening with the body language of
peter on top of the car and everyone
thinking that's toby mcguire but
eventually i think if you are going to
trust anybody it is going to be somebody
like yourself and maybe tom holland's
peter parker is the one that's going to
calm everybody down stating that
universes are colliding and that
basically they're all the same people
give or take a few different details now
loki taught us that variants of
characters could be slightly different
or could be very different and i kind of
think that the only real big differences
that we're going to see in this movie
are of course going to be differences in
appearance their faces obviously don't
look the same and the fact that toby
maguire has internal organic web
shooters whereas tom holland and andrew
garfield do not and if some of the leaks
are true that we've gotten in the past
they are going to be talking about this
fact which i think is going to be just
awesome now the link goes on to say that
the term variant is not mentioned in the
movie but there's a scene where toby has
a triumphal entrance and saves tom and
andrew and as he does this the toby
maguire spider-man theme song plays
which is something that
you gotta play the classic daniel in
spiderman you have to you gotta do that
and it would also make sense that if he
does save them because he probably has
more experience than them yeah he's the
longest-running spider-man of
live-action that we know of i mean it's
wrong it's made for that tom holland has
battled the cosmic entities
yeah that's true he's dealt with a lot
greater things than just the
neighborhood
yeah he's been to space he's he's been
snapped out of existence but either way
man i mean uh how cool would that be if
he is the one who does save them then it
would be toby mcguire's movie yeah which
is what we really what i think it's what
it's shaping up into at this point and i
actually hope that we get a decent
amount of backstory of what's been going
on with the other two spider-man since
we last saw them what is toby mcguire
been up to does he have a daughter with
mj what has andrew garfield been up to
did he actually get with the mary jane
in his universe shailene woodley we were
supposed to get her but we never did i
really hope they dive at least a little
bit into what's been going on and i hope
we get some scenes where they actually
teach tom holland's peter parker some
things that they've learned to
spider-man and then probably tom hall
and spider-man could even teach them a
few things mentoring each other
what would tom holland teach that
uh yeah there's a bunch of star tech
yeah
you want to design your own suit here's
how you all a cart choose what features
you wanted to have don't add the kill
mode we will be shown a little bit of
toby and andrew's universe tom visits
their universes using two different
kinds of magical suits and they do all
talk about uncle ben and this is
something that i am very curious to see
i think that it's probably going to be
one of the most emotional spider-man
scenes that we've seen and i think it's
probably the one thing that each of them
can truly bond on losing uncle ben that
and of course mj but andrew garfield
spider-man doesn't really have an mj so
maybe they can't all bond on that well
bring in shailene woodley yeah this is
what we need for this movie is is to
just give everybody their shot she
didn't she filmed [ __ ] for amazing
spider-man 2 and never never got to see
the light of day i mean to be honest it
would be kind of neat if they did
because it is technically canon to that
movie even though it had to be cut yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i do believe that when the three
spider-man do come together we are going
to get some scenes like this because
think about it they are technically
variants of each other if there's one
thing that loki taught us with the tva
and the different timelines there are
multiple versions of the same character
they are just variants of each other
some are different in big ways some are
different in small ways and i would love
for the three spider-man to talk about
how they're different i hope we get that
organic web shooter scene i hope they
talk about mj and i hope they talk about
uncle ben and aunt may and honestly if
when the two other spider-man do come
talk about your box office performances
that's right
talk about the sequels you didn't get
that would be one of the most epic
scenes ever but let me know what you
think about all of this in the comments
down below is this something you would
want to see happen in the film let me
know don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching
we've seen spiderman fight a lot of
people before but we haven't seen in
live-action spider-man versus other
spider-man so that would be something
special to behold that would be new and
fresh thank you warren for putting this
video together guys subscribe to the
cosmic wonder if you haven't done so
already you subscribe to us hit that
like button
subscribe i already said that hit that
like button
we'll catch you guys soon subscribe